so kind of jumping into it we all know I
think probably everybody here agrees
that javascript is awesome right you
know we all love it and we like to talk
about how javascript is one and it's the
most popular language and it's a kind of
out there by any metric kind of growing
faster than anything else and there's a
lot of reasons for it right there's a
lot of goodness in it and all sorts of
core JavaScript rates some are just sort
of scripting traits and some are
specific JavaScript around you know
built-in memory management and native C
relation with JSON and the fact that
it's naturally scalable various sort of
great capabilities that help us be
productive right helps us runs run
faster and those are amazing
capabilities and their core right and
they are indeed parts of the reason that
javascript is is so successful and that
in general we can create these awesome
things but sometimes the same
capabilities that are sort of unique and
make it awesome also make it vulnerable
right so you look at these different
capabilities and you know well you might
see kind of built-in memory management I
would look for the flaws there and I
will see you know buffer object kind of
leaking memory from server side if you
talk about native serialization
attackers would look and they would say
well you can do some type manipulation
because types are decided in runtime can
I manipulate those can I change so a lot
of this talk today is just going to be
understanding a little bit about how
these capabilities can be abused right
how can attackers use them to to
understand the weaknesses in your system
and run forward the other thing that's
important to remember is that these
vulnerabilities in these types of flaws
don't just happen in your code as part
of a core a kind of a core part of the
JavaScript ecosystem are packages or
libraries NPM you node you know it
doesn't matter if you use power if you
use JavaScript libraries if you just
downloaded Jake jQuery away much and
much of your code is third-party code
open source code that you are using and
you know NPM is also awesome and as a
result it's usage has exploded I'm kind
of picking on NPM but really this is
true for package management as a whole
and it has some like ridiculous number
of times and in packages every time and
it's sort of update this slide and the
result is that a typical application I
will focus on node but this is
increasingly the pattern in in front and
JavaScript as well has a ton of
dependencies hundreds oftentimes
thousands one
that I put it at 350 on average and it
leads to the situation where this is
your app and this is your code and and
this may seem like a negative slide but
it's actually not right you could create
all that orange value by just writing
that little purplish dot orangish value
so it's a good thing but it also is a
risky one or a slightly frightening one
from a security perspective it gives an
entirely different meaning to JavaScript
is one definitely on the dependency
metrics javascript is also leading the
charts so so with that context when you
think about security it's also
remembered to understand that most of
your app's code comes from NPM which
also means that most of your apps of
vulnerabilities come from NPM or come
from these packages so it's they're
different sources that can lead into
your system this is not a theoretical
problem it's practical roughly one in
seven when in aid packages in NPM
carries a known vulnerability doesn't
mean that 14% of them are vulnerable but
the packages themselves use other
packages that use other packages and
within that ecosystem roughly 14% would
bring in a vulnerability with them and
we see that pretty much every node shop
has those and this risks node apps and
this is kind of the focus that I talk
about here but when you talk about
JavaScript it's not limited to just node
it's also true for front-end application
with jQuery has a very prevalent
cross-site scripting vulnerability for
using a specific component of it you
know in react and angular in in with
browserify with all of these components
you pull in NPM packages and again the
same concepts apply for Bower and it
also risks the internet of things so
there's a lot of chatter today about
Mariah but all these like DDoS attacks
massive attacks that take down the
internet that are built on these devices
many of these devices run node apps or
very small lightweight apps and those
could have vulnerabilities so those are
that's kind of setting the stage and
most of the time I'm not gonna spend in
presentation but what we're gonna do is
we're going to try and combine those two
and what we'll do is we'll look at real
world vulnerabilities in these NPM
packages it's I find it more useful than
fabricating an example these are real
packages with real vulnerabilities then
you may actually be using and has a bit
of a dual purpose one of it one aspect
of it is to see the vulnerabilities and
how can you kind of code to not have
them and on the other side
understand a little bit the security
risks you might be pulling in through
those packages and we're gonna focus on
node but as I said this is sort of
applicable more broadly so with that let
me switch out of this and introduce goof
so this is the JavaScript uh clearly it
needs some surprise I'm the first one to
have a model view control like I'm a VC
app in a JavaScript conference and it
allows you to do great things like you
know to-do lists say you know coal mom
and you know it has some markdown
supports to emphasize important things
and you know just just sort of some
features and it uses a bunch of packages
on it I'm gonna use our tool snake it's
on github by the way and on snake slash
goof and you're welcome to clone this
and play with this after and run those
expose yourselves so we're gonna use
sneak 2 to test this application to
trying to find some of these
vulnerabilities and I have some pre open
tabs just in case it doesn't play ball
as we go so we will test our different
repositories and we will find our little
vulnerable app here and we'll see that
goof has a bunch of these vulnerable
dependencies so we're gonna pick on that
and expand and I will kind of randomly
choose a specific set not randomly you
know I've chosen a set of these and show
a bunch of exploits and they're you know
each of these there would be some
explanation that says if this is a
vulnerable package this is the
vulnerability on it and how it manifests
we're gonna start with this one with SD
who here is familiar with SD not that
many it's a it's a package written by
Isaac from from NPM it's used to serve
static resources j/s and CSS on our our
website as well as our about page and it
serves static resources from the the
slash public URL so to attack st st is
susceptible to a directory traversal
vulnerability and typically it would
read the adviser here but you have me so
you don't need to see if this font is
big enough so what happens is you know
if we have some aliases to spare
innocent typing but if we go on and we
do a curl and we fetch the about HTML
page we're switching to the to the
terminal because the browser has all
sorts of convenience features around
normalization and things like that that
kind of get in the way of attackers so
we can get the about page through here
as well
as an attacker if there's a if I know or
I suspect there's a directory traversal
attack then the first thing I'm going to
do is try to break out of the static
file folder this is these are components
that are supposed to serve a set of
static resources but you don't want them
to to serve more than those resources so
I will put a dot dot slash dot dot slash
dot dot slash and if I do that I will
get nothing actually so if you kind of
scroll up you will see that I just got
redirected to the home page of it
because st is a smart package and it has
a security control on it it's not that
they didn't think about security
it just emitted something there's
another way that I can represent a dot
in a URL which is thoughts URL encoding
so I can do % to e % to e % to 8% to e
and that would get me all the way up to
the root and I can do as many of those
that I want and then I might want to add
some sensitive files say like I need to
see passwd and voila I get they D say
passwd so ok so this is just we're just
getting started
simple simple vulnerability and and you
know sort of prevalence enough so we're
getting roamed up we're gonna go from
simple to complex right a vulnerability
at its core the vulnerability that SD
had here and this is a common
vulnerability we see around is just not
dealing with encoding so you have to
think about the different ways that a
character can get represented in your
system so this was on the URL side so we
showed a bit of a URL encoding
vulnerability but let's look at another
one in marked which is more in the HTML
side so who here is familiar with marked
a few more hands so marked is one of the
more popular markdown parsing libraries
out there and it's it gets about 2
million downloads a month you know it's
quite prevalent and we use it to sort of
do that you know emphasize beer and
things like that in our system now we
know that it's susceptible to a
cross-site scripting vulnerability so
what's the first thing we're gonna do
yeah an alert script so we're gonna try
to do something like this will say alert
1 slash script and we'll try to do this
because markdown oftentimes many of
these packages including marked actually
support some HTML snippets in there as
well so we're going to do this and
nothing we're just going to get the text
that's because marked has a sanitized
function in it no surprisingly or not
sanitized is actually turned off by
default so that's something to consider
many of these packages actually have
insecurity faults so they might have a
security feature it might not be on all
the time but in this case we do turn it
on we wanted to be secure but there are
other ways to get a script onto a page
how else can I invoke a script thoughts
yeah I can do a link so I can do there's
a bunch of these I can also do like
attributes I could do a non error I'm
gonna focus on this right I might do a
script like this so this is I'm still
within markdown and I will do an alert
one and then what happens here if I do
this no nothing because mark catches
this and again the sanitize function is
quite comprehensive in fact it is fully
spec compliant so even if I try to do
get fancy here and I will try to use an
HTML entity so HTML entity is kind of
the HTML little sister version of URL
encoding or maybe the other way around
and I will represent this colon with
ampersand in a hash and I think it's a
51 and also from kind of past experience
I know that I also need to encode this
thing - I think of 40 so cheat here a
little bit oh sorry this is 41 and the
other one needed to be 48 58 and these
are just sort of ASCII representations
just numeric representations of this
character and if I do this I'm now
evading some of the security controls
and if I do this I get nothing so again
like security controls can be pretty
tricky and this is on the HTML side
something that's important to understand
is Mark is actually fully expected
compliant and it catches these things
and there's no known exploits that are
not spec compliant but browsers not so
much
so browsers tend to be very tolerant
towards occasional mistakes and if I
come here say after this eight and I say
I'm just gonna zoom in further and I add
the word this so the browser sort of
season oh you know you said an ampersand
and you had like the hash mark and you
had 58 it didn't go all the way but I
kind of know what you mean you know I
think I think you mean a Colin and they
would pull a call in there and then the
remainder of that is just scratch
and this is a valid thing to call in
script and I get a link here and we got
our alert
so vulnerability number two okay so kind
of first lesson from those components
you know one is just again think about
those think about the different
encodings and there's the URL side of it
and there's the HTML side of it
let's get fancier so in both of those
cases we talked about encoding former
abilities but there are other properties
of of JavaScript one of JavaScript's
kind of bigger claims to fame is is that
it's naturally scalable right it is
event-driven so it doesn't require a
thread for processing every incoming
request and it also means that it's a
bit of a point of fragility because if
one of those threads if there is an
action on the thread that makes makes
the thread take a long time some
algorithm some you know infinite loop
like the while true that Jake showed
before right if you had the wrong
conditions you get those prompts in the
browser that says this script is you
know running for too long or you might
take down a thread on the server and
because JavaScript is naturally scalable
even high scale production systems have
a very relatively small number of
threads so it can quickly lead to a
denial of service vulnerabilities now
the most prevalent type of algorithm
that we run although we don't think
about it that way often is a regular
expression it's an algorithm it runs and
depending on how you write the algorithm
but almost always true to an extent the
the time it takes to calculator so to
apply a regular expression is nonlinear
to the length of the input string now
that linearity may be hard or may be low
so depending on on your regular
expression let me kind of switch back to
the slides a moment and show you a bit
of an example of this in a aptly named
problem in regular expression refer to
as catastrophic backtracking so you look
at this regular expression and it's it
seems pretty simple right it's just sort
of ABCDE and you can have like more of
the C occurrences and then maybe a wild
card but what happens here is the
regular expressions are you know very
stubborn they try to match so if you
give them a pattern if you give them a
methodology where they can almost match
like almost get there but not quite they
will
backtrack and they will try to figure
out another path and by having nested
groups like this so first if you have
multiple C's they could apply to the C+
inside the group or they could apply to
the star outside the group and that just
creates a ridiculously large set of
possibilities and most regular
expression engines including the ones in
JavaScript will just try them all and as
a result you can see that by just having
this fairly short string there I know
that's like 30 ish characters I can make
calculating this Rea guys take a second
and then every character I add would
double that amount of time this is on a
sample machine but it's definitely a lot
of time so a moment a very popular
package has recently had this
vulnerability I don't have an easy demo
on that one
but the other package that's very
popular that had it is M s and M s is
used for yeah M s is used for
calculating milliseconds or a timestamp
in the milliseconds so we can say you
know call in two days and it would
calculate those two days to say you know
this is the number of time milliseconds
so I can set a reminder so and this has
this vulnerability a little bit less
extremely so it also has a regular
expression now service one or ability
but it's not quite as extreme so what
we're going to do is first of all we're
going to again kind of make this whole
mom in 20 minutes and I'm going to use
HTTP or HTTP which is the same as a curl
just like with some syntax highlighting
and it goes on if I go back to my
application I will see that I added a
little bit of a record here but what we
will do is we will try to give it an
especially long string so and again I'm
just going to cheat because I have it
just to spare myself some timing here
and what we'll do here is we will print
60,000 fives as the duration and then
we're gonna add another twist which is
we're gonna swap the last character here
instead of being an s to an a so it
almost matches but doesn't quite and
when I do this it takes a long time to
respond now takes a long time to respond
it's not a problem
but the problem is then in the meantime
my application here
isn't responsive so in this case I have
a single thread
and this is just taking out one heroku
Dino here but you know first of all you
can hike up my bill and if I add another
zero you know it wouldn't complete
before the end of this talk now this way
it will I think in about ten or fifteen
seconds a complete an end but this type
of regular expression D now service is a
very prevalent vulnerability and you
have to be very careful about regular
expressions both in your content and in
code overall and now in this case you
might say hey this is sixty thousand
characters who in their white right mind
would sort of past sixty thousand
characters but if it's not explicitly
blocked it is allowed there's nothing
really there the fix in ms by the way in
the package is a little mediocre it they
just capped it I think it's like a
thousand or ten thousand characters the
the right solution is to have a logical
capita to allow twenty characters or
thirty characters in the different
sections so that you truly limited
because otherwise it doesn't take down
the server but it takes a very long
amount of time to process okay so our
application will recover here we can
just kind of go back here and we deleted
a bunch of items so this was read us and
it really comes back to the event loop
and the same times the problem can kind
of happen on front end for my last trick
I will show a couple of other
vulnerabilities so this was an MS and
the last former ability I will show is
in Mongoose who here knows of Mongoose
yeah everybody so so mongoose is no ever
knows mongoose is the way to access
MongoDB is kind of the top one and it
has an interesting vulnerability in that
it tripped over an object called buffer
a buffer is a very very tricky object in
the world of node typically when you
wouldn't work in JavaScript don't really
think about memory management right
memory is this thing that's just sort of
handled for us but buffer allows us to
to play with a little bit and to pre
allocate some memory and it has a couple
of constructors actually I went to the
advisory here but can probably show you
here
if I just do if I just run node move
this up a little bit so you can see it
and if I do I can do new buffer and say
100 and I will get a buffer allocated
with those three characters 1 0 0 but if
I do a new buffer and give it 100 I will
get 100
some memory that's intended however that
memory is not zeros as you can tell here
if I do this a few times you'll notice
that you have very different values in
the different items because this is just
what happens to be in memory and those
hundred bytes that I just allocated so
as an attacker if I can make the
application allocate such memory and
then get access to that this is a remote
memory exposure and if I do this enough
times I basically can get anything
that's in the system's memory including
keys and source code and a lot of those
components this is like heartbleed in
open SSL except running in the node
process so only access to the secrets
that the node process has so buffer has
tripped up many popular packages
Mongoose included and for us we we have
a little bit of a simple schema here
that allows us to we use buffer as the
content field and you know so we can
have images and and other uploads and
buffering and one goes indeed had a
vulnerability where it did not enforce
the the right type that goes into the
component so what we're gonna do to
exploit this is first again we're going
to move to to the browser so we've
already seen that we can do a curl
command to invoke an item but what we
will do is our application like many
node applications also supports another
form of input which is Jason so I can do
echo with instead of a form field of
content adjacent parameter of content
and say fix the bike and if I do this
then if I go back to my application I
will see that we've indeed added an item
that says fix the bike but because this
is Jason I now have the ability to
modify it a little bit and instead of
saying fix the bike I can say 800 like
this which would give me 800 as a string
or because this is just naturally
serializable I can say 800 like this
when this gets serialize din the
application it allocates 800 bytes and
that memory is now a to-do item that's
exposed to me and if I look here I will
see just like a bunch of binary
components if I just do this enough then
you know it depends on the every every
demo I get something different but you
might see some snippets of text and
source code kind of need to trust me
here that if you run this enough and you
do a loop you just sort of extract
of course as an attacker you would kind
of clean up after you you would delete
these items right after so buffer has
tripped many items it's really not just
Mongoose but it's a pretty severe one
because it touches on memory and allows
that sort of be leaked out it also
demonstrates a general a broader problem
called a type manipulation which is true
for any kind of type dynamic typing
language and specifically JavaScript and
can happen with Jason but also can
happen in other components a good
example of that is Q s and Q s if I
parse a string like this I get a JSON
object or a JavaScript object with the
two fields a and B but if I pass it two
A's I get an array and for instance this
tripped - KS which is a linked in
templating library that PayPal used and
actually had a real-world vulnerability
on PayPal because a sanitization logic
only happened on strings nobody
anticipated that an input that came
through the query string could be
anything but a string but with Q s it
can be with Jason it can be so it's just
something to be aware of to say do you
know which type is is the one that
you're using and just sort of as a last
anecdote is type manipulation can also
be used to do something called no sequel
injection so we've shown strings and
arrays but if you have something like
this where you use Mongoose to find
users by a username and a password and
it's meant to be used like this where
you have an admin and a string however
if you can control adjacent input then
you can do something like this and
instead of a string in the password you
pass it a mongoose function that allows
you say greater than nothing which is
everything which means that if you've
done this you just get basically like
SQL injection you get a no SQL injection
to return all the records and depending
on your application logic this might
have just made a pretty major thing so
so just a cap off
I want to show you a couple of things so
before we close off here one thing I do
want to show you is you know we talked
about a bunch of vulnerabilities there
are clearly many many more that we can
talk about hopefully these give you a
tidbit and the other thing you should
talk about is you know on one hand you
should understand the security flaws and
on the other hand you should understand
this application has been made
vulnerable without writing any of this
vulnerable code it just pulled it in
externally so you know a little bit of a
shameless plug you can try out snakes to
help this you know help find those
issues you know free for open source
gonna try it out and it would also help
you fix those issues just sort of open a
fixable request with a single click like
magic and just sort of try it out and
take over protect yourself going back
here so yeah as you sort of seen and I
prove this live don't start hacking
website you know you could get trampled
in trouble and either way it's impolite
I will encourage you above and beyond
sort of general awareness to you first
of all think about the JavaScript
takeaways and these mistakes and and how
can you avoid them in your own code and
second is think about the specific
vulnerabilities in these NPM packages
use a tool like snake like no security
project there's a bunch of these tools
out there to help you find those issues
use tools to help you fix those through
upgrades through patches through
whatever means necessary don't discount
this this is a part of your job this is
a part of software part of software
quality these security concerns so let's
recap you as an NPM are awesome but
please use responsibly
[Applause]
[Music]